Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about
former Vice President Mike Pence.
It's not clear to me whether Mike Pence has
presidential ambitions.
Mike Pence yesterday, however, gave a speech
at the University of Virginia, and it's actually
notable and painful how terrible and uninspiring
a speaker, Mike Pence says, We're going to
look at a couple of clips now, as many of
you, of course, no doubt know if you've been
following American politics for certainly
the last five years, if not the last 10 or
15.
This sort of archetypal prototypical idea
of the alpha male is a really big deal in
right wing politics, in Republican politics,
in the United States.
And Mike Pence, in the context of appearing
to or trying to make Joe Biden look weak in
relation to Vladimir Putin made the case that
he went toe to toe with Putin.
And he told Putin things that he didn't want
to hear.
And it's all just so obviously bogus.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I've also met Vladimir Putin.
Yeah.
I stood toe to toe with him, and I've told
him things he didn't want to hear.
Oh, and let me tell all of you.
Putin only understands strength.
And America must meet this moment with American
strength.
Speaker 1: Now, there's a couple different
things here.
First of all, is he saying he wants a war?
Because if you look at what the Biden administration
has done so far in Ukraine, it's almost everything
short of boots on the ground.
I mean, OK.
The U.S. hasn't that we know, carried out
drone strikes in Russia, but the US has provided
drones to Ukraine.
So short of boots on the ground, it's the
U.S. has done almost everything that can be
done.
There's not a no fly zone, which in theory,
if there was the U.S. could be involved in
enforcing, which is basically World War Three,
if, as I've explained to you before.
But this is the guy who was vice president
to Trump, who said, I'm going to keep us out
of wars.
And he seems to be saying by not going fully
to war.
Joe Biden is not showing strength or strength,
as Mike Pence says.
So that's one piece of this.
The other part of this is I looked at the
video of when Mike Pence met Vladimir Putin,
and we're going to play it here without audio.
It's just background noise is the audio from
when they met.
And it's not really a domineering Mike Pence
when you look at this.
Pence looks extraordinarily tense, and Putin
seems to be the guy kind of controlling the
conversation.
If you watch it, it's a full two minutes.
You see Pence sort of saying OK and nodding.
It's Putin whose agenda is dominating.
It's Putin who's setting the ground rules
and the stakes here.
It didn't really seem like Mike Pence was
the Big Alpha when they actually met.
So, yeah, the idea that Pence is the prototypical
strong alpha male is just an absolute and
total joke.
It really seemed like it was Putin in control
there, so nothing more pathetic than Pence
trying to be the epitome of what he thinks
his supporters need to see as the definition
of of manly strength.
Now, just as a as another note here, the degree
to which Pence is just a terrible speaker
was unavoidably obvious during this speech
at the University of Virginia yesterday.
Check out this Segway.
Mike Pence saying that our hearts are broken
because of the terrible attack that took place
in the New York City subway yesterday, which
we'll talk about later on today.
He says, You know, our prayers are just with
those there.
And then he goes directly into talking about
getting to drive a car now that he's no longer
VP.
And it's a terrible, insensitive Segway, and
he flubs the line like just everything going
wrong.
This guy is such a terrible speaker.
Speaker 2: Our hearts broke this morning with
the headline of the terrible violence that
took place in the subway of New York and our
prayers.
Our prayers are with the injured and the victims
and their families.
You know, one of the advantages of being vice
president is I get to drive my own car again.
One of the disadvantages is I get to pay for
my own gas.
Speaker 1: Wow, what a deeply.
In spite just an electric speaker.
And really, the empathy is just so sincere.
Guys, this guy's horrible.
This this guy.
He he really just knows how to soothe people
in difficult situations.
It's one of the most uninspiring speakers
in the modern Republican Party.
You feel nothing other than revulsion, creepy
revulsion when he speaks.
And I guess what he meant to say is now that
I'm no longer vice president.
I can drive my own car, but instead, he says
one of the great things about being vice president.
It's just all a mess.
Now the political question is, does he have
political ambitions, presidential ambitions?
And do Republicans have any interest in Mike
Pence being the Republican nominee?
Right now, the answer seems no.
If you go to predict it, dawg, which is these
are these are betting markets, you can bet
on just about any political question who will
win the 2024 Republican presidential nomination.
It's still Trump in the lead over Ron DeSantis,
although Ron DeSantis is really closing in
on Trump, and we'll talk about that later.
But Mike Pence down in fourth place, five
cents out of every dollar being bet.
Is going to Mike Pence will be the Republican
nominee in 2024, so we will watch it.
Pence is an absolutely horrible person, a
terrible speaker, but I never after Trump
in 2016, you're not going to hear me say.
X will never be the Republican nominee.
It could be anybody.
It could be Ted Nugent for all I know.
One thing is you don't want to overstate the
common sense and intelligence of the Republican
electorate.
And so I'm not going to